good morning John I've been saving this
one for a long time I'm very excited
about it because there's something very
bizarre about the universe but before I
get to it look at this Beauty look at
this this is the one week that just
until the end of this week you can get
shirts that will someday be legendary
and if there were Pizza Miss pants they
would also be amazing but we don't so I
don't know why I'm talking about it
except to say that these shirts go with
any pants but back to the topic at hand
the universe is a very very very big
place possibly and yet as far as we can
tell both the hottest and the coldest
place in the universe is the same place
and I know this sounds like a riddle but
it's not the second coldest place in the
known universe as we all of course know
and talk about at parties and on office
Zoom calls is the boomerang nebula it is
expelling matter out of it and the most
energetic matter leaves more easily
leaving behind the less energetic matter
which is basically how sweating cools
you off like the hotter molecules of
water evaporate leaving behind the
colder molecules now most of the
universe is quite cold 2.7 Kelvin on
average but the boomerang nebula is a
mere one Kelvin just one degree Celsius
above absolute zero think of it 1.7
degrees Celsius colder than the rest of
the universe they must be there being
like Burr but you can't hear them
because it's in space but the coldest
place in the known universe is so much
colder than the boomerang nebula like
wildly colder and I'm gonna let you
imagine like where would it be what
nebula is colder than that it is at any
given moment in a laboratory on the
planet Earth which is not even a nebula
it's a room a different Labs trade back
and forth which is the coldest at any
given time but the coldest we have ever
gotten something is so much colder than
we could imagine happening naturally
that outside of other intelligent
systems like us we're pretty sure that
it is the coldest any matter in the
universe has ever gotten so like go
Earth and I I hope you're collating at
home because Earth is where you are it's
where you're from it's like you're
playing so the boomerang nebula is one
Kelvin the coldest we we've ever gotten
something on the planet Earth is 38 Pico
kelvins that's 38 trillionths of a
Kelvin humans like let's see a goose do
that now there is maybe a problem
because there's always a problem and the
problem is that black holes are very
weird you might think that black holes
are hot and like maybe they are I don't
know what it's like inside of a
singularity but they have mass and we
used to think they didn't emit any
energy so they would have like zero
temperature like they would be zero
Kelvin but it turns out they do emit
some radiation it's called Hawking
radiation and I don't understand and if
you call the amount of radiation coming
off a black hole it's heat then a black
hole the mass of the Sun would still be
warmer than that lab in Germany where
they made it 38 Pico Cal but the biggest
black holes would actually be colder
than that but what we're doing is just
like taking the amount of radiation and
dividing by the mass of the object and I
don't think that's what we mean when we
say cold so some people will say that
black holes are the coldest thing in the
universe I don't think that's what cold
is and I am very qualified to say what I
think cold is because it's what I think
so I guess in that way like go black
holes you did it but like they don't
actually need my validation that's the
weirdest thing about black holes
actually is that they they don't need
any external validation they just only
care what they think about themselves
which I don't know what that would be
like so that's cold what about heat so
again the universe is a very big place
and there are lots of tremendously
energetic things happening inside of it
there's giant Stars there's Supernova
there's black holes ramming into neutron
stars there's Barbie and Oppenheimer
coming out on the same day in the middle
of summer that was very exciting like
and that can only happen in this
universe but just to start off with
something that's got to be pretty close
to the top right the core of our sun is
15 million Kelvin that's about 30
million degrees Fahrenheit the core of a
super giant star though might have a
temperature of over a billion Kelvin so
the sun's not so hot
I'm gonna forget to bring those
sunglasses back inside Catherine's going
to be so mad when she can't find him
current Hank editing the video and would
you believe they're still right there
this is three days later and I still
haven't brought him inside there's the
pizza John the sign I'm gonna do it
right now but even hotter than that a
super giant star going Supernova at the
end of its life could in some areas
produce a temperature that is over a
hundred billion calories you know how
many degrees Fahrenheit over absolute
zero that is it's like all every degree
got together and had a party and it was
at the core of a supernova so give it
all that as far as we can tell the
hottest thing that has happened in the
universe since the Big Bang so not just
like recently but for the last 13.7
billion years the hottest thing that has
happened in the universe happened on the
planet Earth it happened in a particle
accelerator and the temperatures that
the particles reached was not a hundred
billion Kelvin it was not a trillion
Kelvin it was 7 trillion Kelvin to get a
sense of the scale here imagine
something small and something big uh and
the small thing is the core of a giant
star going Supernova and the big thing
is just a particle accelerator going
faster and furiouser here on the planet
Earth now look the universe is big and
weird and we don't completely understand
it so maybe there are events that are
hotter than this but we don't know about
and also many many billions of years
from now the universe might expand so
much that it will get even colder than
that laboratory in Germany which like
fine go off but it seems like maybe in
the middle time between the big bang and
billions and billions of years from now
at the heat death of the universe the
hottest thing and the coldest thing that
has ever happened happened in one very
tiny little corner of the universe
during a very short period of time both
of those temperatures seem unlikely to
exist naturally in the entire rest of an
infinite universe that's us sometimes I
feel like in the scale of the cosmos we
are so clearly insignificant and
sometimes I think that there's like
nothing more significant than us and I'm
really not sure which one it is John
I'll see you tomorrow and until then
Pizza Miss products are available now at
pizzamist.com or at the pizza Miss app
and they are so great that you will not
be mad at the rest of your shirt so much
has disappointed in them you look at the
rest of your shirts and be like I don't
just I don't see it anymore I'm just
gonna throw them away don't throw them
away but the pizza Miss shirts are only
available this week and at the end of
the week never again no matter what no
amount of pleading will change my mind
you think you can boss me on this you
can't these shirts are limited like we
all are limited love these shirts
because they are like us both the
hottest and the coolest thing in the
universe